à peine arrivés ils sont tout de suite
prise en charge par la croix rouge nous
sommes en plein paris gare de l'est où
une zone d'accueil a été spécialement
ouvertes pour se réfugier ukrainien
c'est pour au la fin d'un calvaire le
début d'une nouvelle pour moi
j'ai peur car je ne sais rien sur ce
pays je ne connais pas la langue et la
culture
nous avons besoin de temps pour nous
adapter
adapté
nous allons rejoindre madrid
car nous avons des amis là-bas ils nous
ont dit qu'ils nous aiderait à trouver
un travail
et une chambre à louer
à ce jour près de 7000 réfugiés ont
choisi l'hexagone alors le gouvernement
prend ses dispositions à ce stade nous
sommes en capacité de faire face aux
réfugiés et aux personnes déplacées qui
arrive d'ukraine de les accueillir
dignement et de faire en sorte que toute
famille ukrainienne est un dispositif y
compris d'hébergement valérie quatre ans
est arrivé à nice il y a trois jours
directement de kiev c'est son premier
jour de maternelle alors difficile de
lâcher la main de sa maman et de sa
grand mère
mais il ne faudra pas longtemps pour lui
redonner le sourire
l'objectif c'est de leur faire reprendre
vie d'enfants qu'elles puissent s'amuser
qu'elles fassent connaissance avec
d'autres enfants et puis que qu'elles
puissent commencer à reprendre des
apprentissages petit à petit des
réfugiés ukrainien il y en a un peu
partout en europe eux finissent leur
périple de quatre jours au portugal sur
le tarmac de l'aéroport militaire de
figo maduro et ce n'est pas tout à fait
terminé ses 267 réfugiés sont attendus
au stade leiria à deux heures de route
de lisbonne
en tant qu'association on va leur donner
un appui psychologique
scolaire humains alimentaire médicale
pour qu'ils puissent commencer à
s'intégrer dans la société et construire
leur vie ici au portugal
trente mille ressortissants ukrainiens
vivre au portugal c'est la cinquième
communauté immigrée du pays